tonight inshaallah
we are going to be speaking about a very
different topic than we usually
are as many of those who are
astute listeners of mine
albeit few they are
astute and very dear to me those who
follow
all of the programs and all of the
lectures that i give
we usually on
when tuesday nights we will speak
about
zed and
as you may see tonight i have no book in
front of me
and that is because i have been missing
for many
weeks i've been missing in action m.i.a
as they say the reason for that
is tragedy
had visited us at our home in my family
it knocked on the door tragedy
forced its way in and i've had to take a
few weeks off
in order to address some of my familial
issues
which i'd to share with the
listeners tonight
this is not something that is very
common for me i don't usually talk about
things that are personal to me
the reason for that is that there are
much greater men
much greater women who are more worthy
of being mentioned than myself and my
petty problems
i say that with honesty and the utmost
of humility
and i do not say that with any kind of
with any kind of disregard for other
people's
hardship
when we look at the scholars of islam
oftentimes we find that they rarely
rarely whether it be contemporary
scholars or whether it be
more specifically scholars of
old of ancient scholars
of ancient times we find that
they rarely speak about themselves
they rarely speak about things that had
occurred
with them or to them they rarely speak
about their own problems in their books
they rarely speak about their own
experiences unless they are writing a
book on history
one of the scholars that comes to mind
that does this a lot is
a very interesting individual
he mentions often in his book in bidet
when he is a book that is a book of
history which speaks about
all of the history of the prophets and
messengers
all the way up until his own death which
he did not document
of course but he wrote the history of
islam
the biography of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam the companions etc etc
all of the prophets that proceeded the
creation of the heavens and the earth
all the way up until his death
and then he has a final volume which he
called
and nihaya which speaks about the end
times
and what's interesting about ibn kathir
is that
even kathir was a very personal man
he liked to write and he liked to share
anecdotes
he liked to share little stories and so
sometimes you'll find in his book
al-birdaya with nihalia which is a
wonderful book
on history and as a matter of fact it is
of such significance that it's been
translated by
non-muslims into german and
english actually
he mentions things arjuba
so he'll put a title for a chapter and
he'll say
a strange occurrence and then you read
what he's talking about and he'll speak
about something that he saw
or something that he witnessed someone
of extreme
intelligence or someone of immense
idiocy whatever it is that he mentions
but this is very rare amongst the
scholars of islam
usually the scholars of islam focus on
those who have preceded them
and this is an issue of humility it's an
issue of humbleness
because my problems my issues
my struggles not only are they
mine and not yours and i should not
burden
others with them however
as well there are men and women who have
preceded us
that have given much more and are much
more worthy of our time and breath
to speak about than our own selves
so it's very rare for me and i do this
why
simply because i wish to try to
follow
the scholars of islam as much as i can i
do not consider myself a scholar
i am not of that caliber
i do try to follow their tracks
in the tasheb
as the scholar as the poet says
that imitation of the noble is a type of
nobility
i have been missing an action because my
mother had actually taken a tumble
my mother is 63 years old and the
reason i'm telling this story is not
just for
you know because i'd to vent or
use this venue for that
this venue is is is for the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
my personal venting
session however
the reason i am telling this story is
because during the past few weeks
through the different levels of grief
that i have gone through
and during the different levels of pain
and
joy that we have experienced as a family
as individuals i have learned a lot and
i'd to share some of those lessons
i've done a lot of reflecting a lot of
contemplation
i've learned a lot about myself
a person who has not experienced true
pain
does not know himself
a person who has not experienced
hunger does not know the level or extent
of his generosity
a person who has not experienced war
does not
know the level or veracity
of his courage a person who has not
experienced
poverty does not know the level of his
patience a person who has not
experienced
pain does not know what is truly in his
heart
i truly believe this and i'll explain as
we continue inshallah
my mother took a tumble
we bought this house probably when i was
about
five years old maybe six years old
she has walked up and down these same
steps probably
hundreds of thousands of times and
she fell off of three steps
you could say maybe about two feet
and somehow as allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
had written it
50 000 years before the first creation
and this is our first lesson the first
lesson of this evening
is a statement of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
which is collected by imam ahmed and
others
in which i believe it is also
collected by atlan
if my memory serves me right
don't quote me on that but it is an
authentic narration
in which some individuals from yemen
came to the prophet salallahu and they
said to him
we would to ask you about the first
of this creation
they said we came to ask you about the
first of this creation
and what it what they were speaking
about with regards to the first of this
creation meaning this
reality this this universe of
ours allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's name is
that is one of his names it doesn't just
mean the one who creates
but it's the one who is in constant
creation and so it doesn't mean that we
are the first of allah's creation that
has always
and eternally been his name and he has
always been the creator
there has been creations that have
preceded us
and there will be creations that will
follow as he says
as he has brought you forth from the
offspring
of a another people likewise allah
subhanahu wa
says
and he will create and he continues
to create that which you all are unaware
of
and that which you all do not know
the first lesson is that
these individuals came to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
they came and asked him about the
beginning of this creation
and again what i mean by the beginning
of this creation has
been cathedra tells us in the beginning
meaning this creation
because the scholars of islam differ
what was created first was it the
heavens and the earth
or was it the throne or was it the water
that the throne was upon
what was created first and the correct
answer
is that
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala created water
which is the source of physical life
he created the throne and then he
created
the heavens and earth after which he
ascended above his throne in a manner
that is befitting of his majesty
and supra rationality subhanahuata
now the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam said
can allah
he said the beginning of this creation
is that there was
a and there was nothing else
meaning that allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
was always there
and there was nothing along with allah
what does that even mean we're not sure
we don't know
we can't fathom that as human beings we
understand the meaning
don't get me don't get me wrong we
understand what that means
but we don't comprehend how that can be
when i tell you allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has
no beginning he always
was and he is a brute fact
and he has no end
what does that even mean to us as human
beings we understand the words
we understand the concept
yet as allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
yet they will never encompass allah in
their knowledge we will never understand
something this
and so he said can allah
[Silence]
that there was allah and nothing else
allah then created the pen
and he said to the pen right and the pen
said what shall i write and allah said
write everything that is to be until the
day of
resurrection and so
at that moment the pen began to write
and the prophet salallahu
he said and this incident took place
50 000 years
before the creation of the heavens and
the earth
it is absolutely unfathomable
the power the beauty
of allah the fountain of knowledge that
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
has brought us
to bathe in if we truly think about it
and its magnificence and its magnitude
you can't help but stand aside and cry
a widow
and so everything that occurs
every breath that i take every thread on
your clothing
every movement every thought
everything that pen wrote
fifty thousand years before the first
creation
and that pen will continue to write and
the pens
of the decree of allah continue
to write in the narration of abi
in musa muslim it's mentioned that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
ascended
when he ascended to meet allah subhanahu
in the tenth year after hijrah
that he reached a place where jibril
said i am not allowed to go past this
point
you must go alone and the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam was brought
so close to the throne of allah that he
said
he said i was brought so close to the
throne of allah
that i heard the writing of the pens
the scholars of islam tell us that the
writing of those
pens that those are the pens
of decree that they are writing
and will continue for eternity to write
everything that is to be it is
documented
in nadali kafikitab in
all of that is in a book
and that is all very easy upon allah
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala says regarding
this incident here this
50 000 years before the creation
he says
he said that no hardship or
crisis no tragedy no misfortune
occurs in the earth anywhere
or in yourselves in your lives
except that it has been written before
we have created all of this creation
now what does that mean does that mean
that we don't have a choice
does that mean that we should say as
some of the
padaria have said that we are
devoid of free will no that's not what's
intended we have free will
but that is the that is the issue there
that many people misunderstand
and that is that there is a difference
between free will and decree
decree is that allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
knows documented
what he knows that he subhanahu wa
ta'ala
allowed and willed for it to happen
and that he created the means for those
choices to be made that's what decree
is
four levels
that the decree of allah when we say
predestination when we say that
the articles of faith are six
man
this came out of the mouth of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
muslim in the narration of umar and the
narration of
jibril came to the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam and he asked him
he said yeah
[Silence]
came to him and asked him explain to me
what
are the pillars of faith what are the
articles of belief
that make you a muslim he
said to believe in allah
to believe in the angels
to believe in the books to believe
in i'm sorry to believe in the books to
believe in the prophets
to believe in the last day the day of
judgment and to believe in decree
good and bad
the good decree and the bad decree what
does that mean
good decree and bad decree that means
that it all comes from allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
good is good for good sake but evil
decree or
bad decree is not for evil sake it is
for some
wisdom that we cannot always see
and so fifty thousand years before the
creation
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala wrote
what is happening right now
every breath every molecule of my body
every time the neurons in my brain fire
allah has written that
in detail allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
wrote this
from his knowledge we said the levels of
decree with ala sunnah are for
in order for you to understand decree
and understand free will
you must understand these concepts
number one allah knows he always has
known he knows all that was
all that is all that is to be
and all that would have been had it been
subhanahu wata'ala second of all
that allah wrote all that was to be
this is written in what is called the
preserved tablets
in the quran allah subhanahu wa
allah says
[Silence]
that i have just mentioned they all make
reference
of elohim
is that narration that the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam explained to us he said
he created the pen
and he said to the pen right the pen
said what shall i write he said right
all that is to be until the day of
resurrection
and from that moment on the pen has been
writing
where did the pen get that knowledge it
got that knowledge from allah subhanahu
and that is written
in the preserved tablet that will never
be changed
nothing that has been written in that
tablet will change why
because it has come to us and it has
come
from the from the knowledge of allah
and if we were to say that allah wrote
something and then changed it and then
came back and changed it again
this reflects deficiency in allah's
knowledge and we know that this is
disbelief this is kufur
everything that happens and occurs to us
has been written
in that sense meaning allah knows what
we are to do with our free will
and he documented it and he wrote it
now what about paradise what about the
hellfire
is that documented as well the answer is
yes
the scholars of islam when they look at
all of the broad picture
they have mentioned that there are eight
things
that are eternal of this creation
eight things there are
eight things which are eternal
of this creation meaning they have a
beginning
but they have no end
number one is paradise
it has a beginning it has no end number
two is the hellfire
it has a beginning it has no end
number three is the pen that we spoke
about
number four is the preserved tablet
number five is the soul of the human
being
number six is the final vertebrae
which is referred to as the coccyx or
the tailbone of the human being
because that is what we will all be
resurrected from
number seven is the throne of allah
and number eight is the footstool of
that throne
these are eight things that the scholars
of islam have mentioned
have no end and of those scholars
is shaykh islam
he has mentioned these things i believe
in the book
which is a book regarding the
paradise and so these eight things they
have a beginning but they have no end
and so as we are all in paradise and i
pray
sincerely and earnestly to allah that
everyone listening gin or human
to me right now including myself
that we will all be in paradise together
and that
the pen will be continuing to write
everything that we do
and say and speak in paradise
so this is the first lesson
50 000 years before the creation allah
created the pen
this is the second level which is called
al-kitab
the third level is called el erada
what is
the will of allah
allah first knows always did
he then wrote this is of his actions
number three he willed for what he wrote
to
happen because nothing
happens without the will of allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
not one thing takes place without allah
allowing it to happen
every time your heart beats
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has given it
permission to beat
every time do not take that for granted
as we are disobeying allah and i am the
first of
all of you for someone to to to
to to to take this admonishment
with regards to our disobedience
we are all guilty in god's court
and it's not about being innocent it's
about
trying to be innocent it's about
asking for forgiveness that's what it
really is about
that every time your heart beats
to provide your mind and your body with
oxygen in order for you to
sin you must know that allah has given
that heart permission
just think about that next time
anyhow nothing occurs
in this earth nothing occurs in the
creation of allah without his will
he wills for it to happen
a person may now ask what about
evil does allah
will evil to happen
and the answer is yes
because nothing happens
without allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's will
but there is a difference between when
allah wills
good and when allah wills evil
or bad evil
there's a couple of reasons why
number one there is no such thing
as pure evil
that no good comes as a result of
there is pure evil for example
the worship of idols is pure evil is it
not yes
but the action of worshiping idols
some good is caused by that
even if only the sending of the
messengers to humanity
the communication of god to man
this is a great good that has only come
about because we need
guidance etc etc
even the creation of the devil himself
iblis even
the creation of iblis has
good in it as a matter of fact
allah wrote in one of his books that
he listed more than 20 benefits
for the existence of iblis and i know
this
sounds a little bit absurd to some
people but
we have to think about these things
because some people think that
good comes from god and evil comes from
man
and that is not correct because allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says
time and time again throughout the quran
allah is the creator of everything
is iblis considered part of everything
yes he is is evil
considered part of everything yes it is
there is a narration on the authority of
ibn omar
collected by a daily and this narration
off
has been authenticated by
some scholars of hadith honestly i
believe it is a statement of one of the
companions
any time you hear a narration that has
been collected by a
daily
daily live
that if allah did not desire that evil
exist he would not have created iblis
but there is a difference between evil
for evil sake
and evil which a good
comes as a result of it
because we live in a world of contrast
we consider thirst to be something evil
and we considered a drink of water to be
something that is good
and pure but you can only enjoy
that good if you first experience
that evil there has to be a contrast
and if you can imagine with me the
amount of
people that will enter
paradise simply as a result
of disobeying iblis it is staggering
that alone is enough because when iblees
and his troops
assail the believer from all sides
[Silence]
and scream and yell and raise your voice
and try to intimidate into submission as
many of my servants as you choose
try and send your calvary against them
and send your foot soldiers against them
and try to
form partnerships and take a portion of
their wealth and their
children and promise them whatever you
want
but the promises of iblees are all
lies and false hopes
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala after saying
to iblis this
he said
he said indeed my true servants
you will have no power over them not
with all your calvary and all of
all of your men you will have no power
over them
and it is enough of a protector
and a disposer and rectifier of affairs
that allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala is
beautiful the quran is
and so
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala creates good
he creates evil yes
evil things happen and they are by the
will of allah
however they are not evil in an entire
way
okay there is an element of evil to them
but there is an overwhelming amount of
good that comes from them most of the
time
we don't know what it is as human beings
why do volcanoes happen why do tsunamis
happen
why is it a six-year-old boy is riding
down the street and gets hit down by a
car and dies
why did the good die young and the
wicked live old why
why why these questions that come to us
and the answer is the human brain
weighs only about three pounds
you cannot figure out the cosmos with
three pounds of gray matter
you must know your limitations
and we have to understand that we do not
know
why allah does always we don't always
know why
but we do know who he is and this is all
we need to know
that's faith true
faith is not understanding always why
true faith is understanding who
and if we go home tonight with nothing
but that
we will have a wealth of wisdom
what does that mean what i am saying is
that
allah describes himself and says
he is not asked about what he does yet
they will all be asked
he says yet he has also
told us who he is
he is he is a rahim
he is a shakur
all of these names of allah so he told
us who he is
he didn't always explain to us why he
does what he does
but he told us who he is and so we have
to take whatever we
do not understand of his actions and we
have to apply them to those names
and if we do that and if we can have the
courage
and the hope and the reason and if we
can have the audacity
to do that that is true faith
that is exactly what faith is
is when you don't understand why allah
is doing
but you understand who allah is
and that is enough for you that's what
tawakkul is
and when we look at the story of khadr
and musa
what did he say he said to musa
if you want to follow me and you want to
learn from me
my one condition is that you don't ask
me why
i am doing what i am doing
musa said fine sure it's human nature
that we want to understand
why are you doing this
but allah described al khadr to musa
before he met him
he said that musa came upon a man who
was referring to as al-qaeda
a man whom we have given from us
particular mercy an additional portion
of mercy
and we have taught him knowledge
directly from us
now if you think about that allah
described
al khadr to us he described al-khadr
but he did not explain his actions
and musa alaihis was
he couldn't help but ask and then we
learned
we learned that what looked bad actually
was a blessing
and what was a what looked a
blessing was actually a curse
we saw that and this is a
very small microcosm
meaning or a microcosm of
a parable of who allah subhanahu is to
us
we don't know why he does what he does
we don't know
sometimes we do he's explained some
things to us
he's explained things why do wicked
people live so long and so prosperously
in naman
he explained it but he didn't explain
everything
and when tragedy knocks on your door and
it will
knock on your door that is part of our
lives
when it does remember allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala's names
and attributes do not try to figure out
allah
because he is beyond anything that we
can comprehend
we've spoken a lot tonight and there is
hadith i do not to go over 35
minutes
but this is a very important issue that
we spoke about
this will be enough for tonight we will
try to continue this next week if we get
permission to do so
i believe it is a very important
a very important topic that we are
discussing
yes we've come off the subject a little
bit
but this is something that if many of us
and more of us would understand
more of us would have a lot more wisdom
and a much easier life
we ask allah subhanahu wa ta'ala that he
bless us all with paradise
that he teach us of wisdom that he
bathed us in his
fountain of knowledge subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
and that he forgive us for our sins and
that he not cause our sins to be a
barrier between us and himself
allah
wherever there's a